it's been three agonizing years since
the final episode of game of thrones
aired and in just one month we'll be
getting the first in a series of
spin-offs house of the dragon i'm not
gonna waste any of your time this is a
full breakdown of the new trailer
spoilers ahead and if you haven't seen
the trailer yet i've left a link to it
in the description below our first shot
is of the great hall a little darker
than we're used to and that may be
because it's undergoing some work as you
can tell by the sandbag bucket and what
looks to be scaffolding over here and on
this side some tools or paintbrushes we
get a better shot of it here in the
first teaser released in october of
2021. walking down the middle is renera
targaryen daughter of king viserys the
first and next in line to the throne
however sitting on the throne is her
uncle damon targaryen we'll later see a
shot of damon wearing the same white
shirt as seen on the person on this
throne you may have also noticed this
large array of swords surrounding the
throne a change made from the got series
to better align with its description in
the book this shot of king viserys
through fire is accompanied by his
voiceover about a dream a dream of
putting his heir on the throne through
the forest we get a shot of a targaryen
and member of the kingsguard if i were
to hazard a guess this is sir kristen
cole or harold westerling following
renera this aligns with the king's dream
of thundering hooves splintering shields
and ringing swords here we have daemon
battling kristen cole this is a
tournament to celebrate the ascension of
king viserys to the iron throne and cole
ends up winning this giving the victors
laurel to young rhaenyra the king will
later name kola near his sworn shield
which is what leads me to believe this
might be a shot of the two of them this
is likely cole too with rhaenyra blurred
in the background we'll later see a
similar campfire scene with him in it
here we see viserys on the throne and
someone riding a dragon in front of the
dragon pit the building that houses the
dragons we actually saw the dragonpit in
season 7 of game of thrones now there
are a few dragons in this trailer i'm
not going to get into too much detail
about them as there's still huge debate
online of which dragon is which and
who's riding who here we have a guarded
escort arriving and what i think is
king's landing you can make out what
appears to be house targaryen banners
over here this was actually filmed in
trujillo spain where the statue has been
replaced with that of a dragons at a
meeting of the small council king
viserys which you can tell by his ring
here puts what appears to be some sort
of token used for voting other members
of the council have their own too
however it looks like viserys is the
only white one sir otto hindtower
reminds the king the importance of
choosing his successor otto will become
an antagonist in damon's quest for the
throne if you look closely you'll also
see rhaenyra here serving the men
refreshments here we have a better view
of that jousting tournament we saw
glimpses of earlier not gonna lie
damon's get up here looks pretty badass
a young rhaenyra watches on we'll later
see her alongside her future husband
leonard valarion in the books it's
hinted that he's gay which may implies
this isn't the happiest of marriages
during the council meeting we hear otto
say that viserys's firstborn should have
a claim to the throne but it's lionel
strong lord of harrenhal who reminds him
that a woman has never sat on the throne
it's coreless velaryon elena's father
and head of house velaryon that says the
king already has an heir and that's
daemon targaryen this puts the king in a
tough spot and he doesn't want to choose
between his brother and daughter damon
looks to have several loyal members of
the city watch also known as the gold
cloaks damon commanded the watch from
104 to
ac here we see renera watching over some
knights from houses karen mallister
corbert tarly and craighall you can see
carvings of their house sigils here
perhaps they've arrived to compete in
that jousting tournament and with her as
a contender for the throne these men may
want to marry her alongside renera looks
to be sir harold westerling the current
lord commander of the kingsguard in the
top left we can make out princess
rhaenys velarion also known as the queen
who never was since her claim to the
throne was denied as a result of her
being a woman something she'll remind
young rhaenyra saying that men would
rather the realm put to the torch than
see a woman ascend the throne here's a
better look at kristen cole that guy we
saw battling at the tournament he'll go
on to become commander of the kingsguard
after harold westerling's death when
ronira's marriage arrangement to lanor
is announced kristen professes his love
to her wanting to run away so they can
be together but this does not happen
here we have the smokey walls of
dragonstone as two parties emerge from
either side from the previous trailer we
can see this is daemon and sir otto
hightower here we have two dragons i
think one for sure is karaxis not
exactly sure who the other one is reynus
tells her husband that knives will come
out as rhaenyra's succession will be
challenged this is followed by a shot of
damon entering the great hall wearing
the stepstone's crown as sir harold
westerlink holds him back with a sword
damon has actually come here to offer
the crown and bend the knee to his
brother here's a shot of alison
hightower daughter of otto who is shown
with a company voiceover of rhaenyra
that the king's duty is to find a new
wife viserys will later choose alison as
this new queen and over time a rivalry
will brew between her and rhaenyra the
king tells damon his choice to name
rhaenyra as his heir which is news to
damon because he believes himself to be
that rightful heir back at dragonstone
we have a better glimpse of that
confrontation between daemon and serato
damon is holding a dragon egg here and
to his left we can make out messaria
confidante and daemon's unofficial
mistress rhaenyra asks cole if he thinks
the realm will accept her as their queen
which is followed by uranus telling
renera that no woman will ever be on the
throne because that is the order of
things there's this brilliant cut to
older rhaenyra telling us that when
she's queen she will then create a new
order we get a couple of shots of damon
in the aftermath of a great battle this
could be one of two things the war of
the stepstones which saw damon team up
with corliss velaryon to take on the
triarchy in an attempt to gain his own
kingdom or the battle of the gullet one
of the bloodiest sea battles in
westerosi history which occurred during
the dance of dragons a shot of a heated
dragon egg is accompanied by voice over
of viserys that dragons are a power man
should have never trifled with looks
like damon is not heeding his brother's
words here damon sues karaxis and i
gotta say it looks damn good this closer
shot even looks like it could be part
practical here we have what appears to
be aemond targaryen claiming his dragon
vagar and apologies if i get some of
these pronunciations wrong eamond is the
second son of king viserys and alicent
hightower this is set in an alcove
overlooking some water as a dragon spews
fire it reminds me of a pirate's cove
with miscellaneous treasure tossed to
the side if you zoom in on the man here
it appears to be the same masked guy
we'll see later this is likely crab
feeder who's an antagonist in daemon's
war of the stepstones here's a shot of
alicent and rhaenyra notice the
differing green and black dresses in the
books greens vs blacks becomes a common
way of referring to the queens and
princesses parties respectively alison
warns what may be her son aegon looking
like he just came home from a brothel
that if renera comes into power she can
cut off any challenge to her secession
meaning kill aegon and his siblings it
might be possible this could be her
daughter helena more shots of the gold
cloaks cheering on damon and renera
talking to damon about how alicent will
block her way to the throne we get this
shot of a crown on top of what could be
the dead body of the king here we have
cole fighting aymond and these two great
shots of younger allicent and rhaenyra
juxtaposed with their older selves
highlighting how they once were close
but drifted apart here's corliss running
into battle where you can see the
seahorse emblem on his helm this appears
to be from that same battle we saw
earlier alison cries likely as she finds
out her husband will soon be dead which
is followed by reynus asking her if she
ever imagined herself on the iron throne
a shot of a dragon coming over the walls
at dragonstone with sir otto and his
cohort in the foreground here we have a
knight representing house baratheon at
the tournament perhaps boors or bormond
followed by the valarians entering a
feast more aftermath of that battle with
tons of crabs skittering around not
exactly sure who this guy is brutally
finishing someone off is it crab feeder
or someone else he appears to be
wielding a hammer damon also holds a
hammer while bending the knee to viserys
perhaps it's a victory token of his
defeat of crab feeder this looks to be
from that same battle you can see the
beach over to the right with what could
be the dragon's sea smoke blasting away
at the enemy below this looks to be
viserys and a young allison if you look
closely she might be pregnant another
shot of daemon as part of the city watch
and alison stealing a dagger to attack
rhaenyra this might be alison's exacting
revenge on rhaenyra rhaenyra's son
lucerus slashed the eye of allison's son
eamonn this wide shot gives us a better
look at what might be happening on the
top right we can make it what seems to
be viserys on the ground holding a cane
he's probably sick at this point and
maybe it was his dagger that alison
stole damon and cole seemed to be at it
over here with harold telling them to
knock it off and corliss protects his
family to the left viserys seems to be
getting it on with someone maybe his
niece renera who he'll later wed here's
a shot of karaxis with what appears to
be a saddle around his neck and the
final shot is of a dragon with green
eyes here likely cyrox and that's where
the trailer leaves us now there's only
one more month before house of the
dragon comes out i'll be giving the book
another read in the meantime but you can
help me out by liking and subscribing
and leaving a comment on what you think
of this prequel stick around till then
because i'll be breaking down every
episode of the season thanks for
watching